The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
In today's lesson,
hopefully we will
begin to reap the
rewards of our digression
into the subject
of linear algebra.
Recall that in the
last few lectures, what
we have been dealing with is
the problem of inverting systems
of linear equations.
And what we would
like to do today
is to tackle the
more general problem
of inverting systems
of equations,
even if the equations
are not linear.
And with this in
mind, I simply entitle
today's lesson "Inverting More
General Systems of Equations."
And by way of a
very brief review,
recall that given the linear
system y_1 equals a_(1,1)*x_1
plus, et cetera, a_(1,n)*x_n; up
to y_n equals a_(n,1)*x_1 plus,
et cetera, a_(n,n)*x_n.
We saw that that system was
invertible, meaning what?
That we could solve
this system for the x's
as linear combinations
of the y's if
and only if the inverse of
the matrix of coefficients
of this system exists.
And in terms of determinants,
recall that that means if
and only if the determinant
of the matrix of coefficients
is not 0.
If the determinant of the matrix
of coefficients was 0, then
we saw that y_1 up to
y_n are not independent.
In fact, in that
context, that's where
we came to grips with the
concept of a constraint,
that the constraint actually
turned out to be what?
The fact that the y's
were not independent.
Meaning that we could express
a linear combination of the y's
equal to 0.
So what situation
were we at then?
Given a linear system, if
the matrix of coefficients
does not have its
determinant equal to 0,
the system is invertible.
We can solve for the
x's in terms of the y's.
If the determinant of the
matrix of coefficients is 0's,
the y's are not
linearly independent.
In other words, the
system is not invertible.
And now what we
would like to do is
to tackle the more general
problem of inverting
any system of equations.
And by any, I mean what?
Now we have y_1 is f
sub 1 of x_1 up to x_n,
et cetera, y sub n is f
sub n of x_1 up to x_n.
And now what we're
saying is, we do not
know whether the f's
are linear or not.
In fact, if they
are linear, we're
back to, as a special case,
what we've tackled before.
But now we're assuming that
these need not be linear.
And what we would like
to do is to invert
this system, assuming, of
course, that such an inversion
is possible.
Again, what do we
mean by the inversion?
We mean, somehow, we
would like to know that
given this system of n
equations and n unknowns,
where the y's are expressed
explicitly in terms of the x's,
can we invert this,
and express the x's
in terms of the y's, either
explicitly or implicitly?
That's the problem that
we'd like to tackle.
And what we're going
to use to tackle this
is our old friend,
the differential,
the linear approximation,
again, that
motivated our whole
study of linear systems
in the first place.
Remember, we already
know that if y_1
is a differentiable
function of x_1 up to x_n,
that delta y_1
sub tan is exactly
equal to the partial of f_1
with respect to x_1 times
delta x_1 plus, et cetera, the
partial of f_1 with respect
to x_n times delta x_n.
And in terms of reviewing
the notation, because we will
use it later in
the lecture, notice
that delta y_1 tan was what
we abbreviated to be dy_1
And that delta x_1
up to delta x_n
are abbreviated respectively
as dx_1 up to dx_n.
Generalization of what we
did for the differential
in the case of one
independent variable and we
went through this
discussion when
we talked about exact
differentials in block three.
And in this similar
way, we could of course
express delta y_2
tan, et cetera,
and we can talk about the
linear approximations.
All right?
Not the true delta y's now, but
the linear part of the delta
y's, the delta y_1 sub
tan, or if you prefer,
delta y_1 sub lin,
L-I-N. All right?
And the key point now is what?
If the y's happen to be
continuously differentiable
functions of the x's in a
neighborhood of the point
x bar equals a bar-- in
other words, x_1 up to x_n
is equal to a_1
comma, et cetera,
up to a_n-- x_1 equals
a_1, x_2 equals a_2,
et cetera-- then near that
point, what we're saying
is what?
That the error term
goes to 0 very rapidly.
And as long as the functions
are continuously differentiable,
it means what?
That the change in
y is approximately
equal to the change
in y sub tan.
So that what we're
saying is-- and remember
this is what motivated
our linear systems
in the first place-- that
delta y_1 is approximately
the partial of y_1
with respect to x_1,
evaluated when x bar is a bar,
times delta x_1 plus et cetera,
the partial of y_1 with
respect to x_n, also evaluated
when x bar equals a bar,
times delta x sub n et cetera,
down to delta y sub
n is approximately
equal to the partial of y sub
n with respect to x_1 times
delta x_1, plus et cetera, the
partial of y sub n with respect
to x sub n times delta x_n,
where all of these partials
are evaluated specifically
at the point x bar equals a bar.
The point being what?
That since we're evaluating
all these partials
at a particular point, every
one of these coefficients
is a constant.
You see in general, these
partial derivatives are
functions, but as soon as we
evaluate them at a given value,
they become specific numbers.
So this is now what?
On the right-hand side,
we have a linear system,
and the point is that we are
using the fundamental result
that we can use the linear
approximation as being
very nearly equal to
the true change in y.
And it's in that
sense that we have
derived our system of n linear
equations and n unknowns.
You see, this is
a linear system.
The approximation-- again,
let me emphasize that,
because it's very important.
The approximation
hinges on the fact
that what this is
exactly equal to
would be delta y_1 tan
et cetera, delta y sub n.
But we're assuming
that these are
close enough in a small
enough neighborhood of x
bar equals a bar, so that we can
make this particular statement.
So this is a linear system.
And because it is
a linear system,
we're back to our special case
that this system is invertible
if and only if the determinant
of the coefficients-- matrix
coefficients-- is not 0.
And what is that
matrix coefficient?
It consists of n
rows and n columns,
and the row is determined
by the subscript on the y,
and the column is determined
by the subscript on the x.
So we write that matrix
as the partial of y
sub i with respect to x sub j.
In other words, the i-th
row involves the y's
and the j-th column the x.
All right?
And that's exactly, then, how we
handle this particular system.
OK?
Quite mechanically.
And let's just summarize
that, then, very quickly.
If f sub 1 et cetera and
f sub n are continuously
differentiable functions
of x_1 up to x_n near x bar
equals a bar, then the
system y_1 equals f_1 of x_1
up to x_n et cetera, y_n
equals f sub n of x_1 up
to x_n-- that system is
invertible if and only
if the determinant--
the n by n determinant
whose entry in i-th row, j-th
column is the partial of y
sub i with respect
to x sub j-- if
and only if that
determinant is not 0.
Now what does that mean, to
say that it's invertible?
It means that we can solve for
the x's in terms of the y's.
Now we may not be able
to do that explicitly.
The best we may be able to
do is to do that implicitly,
meaning this.
Let me just come
back to something
I said before to make
sure that there's
no misunderstanding about this.
What we're saying is, that in
this particular linear system
of equations, as long as this
determinant of coefficients is
not 0, we can explicitly solve
for delta x_1 up to delta x_n
in terms of delta
y_1 up to delta y_n,
even if we may not be
able to solve explicitly
for the x's in terms of the y's.
In other words,
the crucial point
is, we can solve
for the changes in x
in terms of the changes in y.
And that is implicitly enough
to see what the x's look like
in terms of the y's.
Once we know what
the change of x
looks like in terms
of the change in y,
then we really
know what x itself
looks like in terms
of the y's, even
as I say it may be implicitly
rather than explicitly.
At any rate, this
matrix is so important
that it's given a
very special name.
Definition: The
matrix whose entry
in the i-th row, j-th
column is the partial
of y sub i with respect to x
sub j is called the Jacobian.
I put "matrix" in
quotation marks
here, because some people
refer to the Jacobian
meaning a matrix.
Other people call the Jacobian
the determinant of the Jacobian
matrix.
I'm not going to make
any distinction this way.
It'll be clear from context.
Usually when I say
the "Jacobian,"
I will mean the Jacobian matrix.
I might sometimes mean
the Jacobian determinant.
And so to avoid ambiguity,
I will hopefully
say "Jacobian matrix"
when I mean the matrix,
and "Jacobian determinant"
when I mean the determinant.
But should I forget to
do this, or should you
read a textbook where
the word Jacobian is
used without the
proper noun after it,
it should be clear from
context which is meant.
But at any rate, that's what
we mean by the Jacobian of y_1
up to y_n with respect
to x_1 up to x_n.
And this Jacobian matrix is
often abbreviated by-- you
either write J for
Jacobian of y_1
up to y_n over x_1 up to x_n.
Or else you use a modification
of the partial derivative
notation.
And you sort of read this as
if it said the partial of y_1
up to y_n divided by the
partial of x_1 up to x_n.
And again, there
is the same analogy
between why this
notation was invented
and why the notation dy
divided by dx was invented.
But in terms of giving you a
general overview of what we're
interested in, I
think I would like
to leave the
discussion of why we
write this in a fractional
form to the homework.
In other words, as either a
supplement to the learning
exercises or else as part of
the supplementary notes in one
form or another,
we will take care
of all of the computational
aspects of how
one handles the Jacobian.
But what I wanted to
do now was to emphasize
how one uses the Jacobian matrix
and differentials to invert
systems of n equations
in n unknowns.
And I will use the
technique that's
used right in the
textbook, and which
is part of the assignment
for today's unit.
The example that
I have in mind--
I simply picked the
usual case, n equals 2,
so that things don't
get that messy.
Using again, the
standard notation
when one deals with two
independent variables,
let u equal x squared
minus y squared.
Let v equal to 2x*y.
Let's suppose now
that I would like
to find the partial
of x with respect
for u, treating v as the
other independent variable.
You see, again, I want
to review this thing.
When I say find the
partial of x with respect
to u holding v
constant, it is not
the same as finding
the partial of u
with respect to x from here
and then just inverting it.
Namely the partial of u
with respect to x here
assumes that y is
being held constant.
And if you then invert that,
recall that what you're finding
is the partial of x with
respect to u treating y
as the other variable.
We want the partial
of x with respect
to u treating u and v as the
pair of independent variables.
Why?
Because that's exactly what you
mean by inverting this system.
This system as given
expresses u and v
in terms of the pair of
independent variables x and y.
And now what you'd like to do
is express the pair of variables
x and y in terms of the
independent variables u and v,
assuming of course,
that u and v are indeed
independent variables.
The mechanical solution
is simply this.
Using the language
of differentials,
we write down du and dv.
Namely, du is what?
The partial of u with
respect to x times dx,
plus the partial of u with
respect to y times dy.
And from the relationship that
u equals x squared minus y
squared, we see that du
is 2x*dx minus 2y*dy.
Similarly, since the partial
of v with respect to x is 2y,
and the partial of v
with respect to y is 2x,
we see that dv is
2y*dx plus 2x*dy.
If we now assume that
this is evaluated
at some point (x_0, y_0),
what do we have over here?
Once we've picked out
a point (x_0, y_0)
to evaluate this at-- and I
left out that because it simply
would make the
notation too long,
but I'll talk about
that more later.
Assuming that we've evaluated
this at a particular fixed
value of x and y, we have what?
du is some constant times dx
plus some constant times dy.
dv is some constant times dx
In other words, du
and dv are expressed
as linear combinations
of dx and dy.
We know how to invert
this type of a system,
assuming that it's invertible.
Sparing you the details,
what I'm saying is what?
I could multiply,
say, the top equation
by x, the bottom equation by y.
And when I add them, the terms
involving dy will drop out.
And I will get x*du plus
y*dv is 2x*dx plus 2y*dx.
In other words twice--
it's 2 x squared.
I multiply the top equation by
x, the bottom equation by y.
So the right-hand
side here becomes
2 x squared dx plus 2 y
squared dx, which is twice
x squared plus y squared dx.
I now divide both
sides of the equation
through by twice x
squared plus y squared.
I wind up with the
fact that dx is
x over twice the quantity x
squared plus y squared du,
plus the quantity y over twice
x squared plus y squared dv.
Recall that I also
know by definition
that dx is the partial
of x with respect
to u times du plus the partial
of x with respect to v times
dv, recalling from our
lecture on exact differentials
that the only way two
differentials in terms
of the du and dv can be
equal is if they're equal
coefficient by coefficient.
I can therefore equate
the two coefficients of du
to conclude that the partial
of x with respect to u
is x over 2 times the quantity
x squared plus y squared.
In fact, I can get the
extra piece of information,
even though I wasn't asked
for that in this problem,
that the partial of
x with respect to v
is y over twice the quantity
x squared plus y squared.
By the way, observe,
purely algebraically,
that the only time I
would be in any difficulty
with this procedure is if
x squared plus y squared
happened to equal 0.
In other words, if x squared
plus y squared happened
to equal 0, then to
divide through by twice
x squared plus y squared is
equivalent to dividing through
by 0.
And division by 0
is not permissible.
In other words,
somehow or other,
I must take into consideration
that I am in trouble if x
squared plus y squared is 0.
Notice, by the way,
that the only time
that x squared plus
y squared can be 0
is if both x and y are 0.
And that means, again,
that somehow or other,
at the point 0 comma 0-- in
a neighborhood of the point 0
comma 0, in the
neighborhood of the origin,
I can expect to have a
little bit of trouble.
Now again, the main
aim of the lecture
is to give you an overview.
The trouble that
comes in at the origin
will again be left
for the exercises.
In a learning exercise, we will
discuss just what goes wrong
if you take a neighborhood
of the origin,
to discuss the change of
variables u equals x squared
minus y squared, v equals 2x*y.
Suffice it to say,
for the time being,
that the system of equations
u equals x squared minus y
squared, v equals 2x*y is
invertible in any neighborhood
of a point x_0 comma y_0 except
in that one possible case when
you have chosen as the
point (x_0, y_0) the origin.
At any rate, to take
this problem away
from the specific
concrete example
that we've been talking
about, and to put
this in terms of a more
general perspective,
let's go back more abstractly
to the more general system.
Let's suppose now
that u and v are
any two continuously
differentiable functions
of x and y.
Let u be f of x, y.
Let v equal to g of x, y.
And what we're saying
is, if you pick
a particular point x_0 comma
y_0, then by mechanically
using the total
differential, we have
that du is the partial
of f with respect
to x evaluated at (x_0, y_0)
times dx, plus the partial of f
with respect to y, evaluated
at (x_0, y_0) times dy.
We have that dv is the
partial of g with respect
to x evaluated at
(x_0, y_0) times dx
plus the partial
of g with respect
to y, evaluated at
(x_0, y_0) times dy.
What is this now?
This is a linear system of
two equations in two unknowns.
du and dv are linear
combinations of the dx and dy.
The key point being again--
that's why I put this in here
specifically, with the
x sub 0 and the y sub
0-- the key point
is that as soon
as you evaluate a partial
derivative at a fixed point,
the value is a constant,
not a variable.
So this is what?
A linear system.
We have du as a constant times
the x plus a constant times dy.
dv is a constant times dx
plus a constant times dy.
Again, to make a
long story short,
I can solve for dx in
terms of du and dv.
I can solve for dy in terms
of du and dv, provided what?
That my matrix of
coefficients does not
have its determinant equal to 0.
And to review this
more explicitly
so you see the mechanics, all
I'm saying is, to solve for dx,
I can multiply the top
equation by the partial
of g with respect to y
evaluated at (x_0, y_0).
I can multiply the bottom
equation by minus the partial
of f with respect to y
evaluated at (x_0, y_0).
And then when I add
these two equations,
the dy term will drop out.
Again, leaving the
details for you,
it turns out that dx is what?
The partial of g
with respect to y--
and I've abbreviated this
again, this means what?
Evaluated at (x_0, y_0).
Times du minus the partial of f
with respect to y at (x_0, y_0)
times dv over the
partial of f with respect
to x times the partial
with g with respect
to y minus the partial
of f with respect to y
times the partial of
g with respect to x.
And notice, of course, that
this denominator is precisely
our matrix of coefficients.
f sub x, f sub y;
g sub x, g sub y.
And the only place I've
taken a liberty here
is to use the abbreviation of
leaving out the (x_0, y_0).
And the key point is what?
The only place I am
going to get in trouble
is if this denominator
happens to be 0.
In the two by two
case-- in other words,
in the case of two
equations and two unknowns,
notice that we
can see explicitly
what goes wrong when the
determinant of coefficients
is 0.
The determinant of coefficients
is just this denominator.
And when that denominator
is 0, we're in trouble.
In other words, the only time
we cannot invert this system,
the only time we cannot find
delta x and delta y in terms
of du and dv is when
this determinant is 0.
Now you see, I think this is
pretty straightforward stuff.
The textbook has
a section on this,
as you will be reading shortly.
It is not hard to work
this mechanically.
And then the
question comes up is,
how come when you pick up a
book on advanced calculus,
there's usually a huge chapter
on Jacobians and inversion?
Why isn't it this simple
in the advanced textbooks?
Why can we have it in our
book this simply, but yet,
in the advanced book, why is
there so much more to this
beneath the surface?
The answer behind all
of this is quite subtle.
In fact, the major
subtlety is this.
And that is that
the notation du--
and for that matter, dv or dx
or dy or dx_1 dx_2, whatever
you're using here--
is ambiguous.
And it's ambiguous for
the following reason.
Recall how we defined the
meaning of the symbol du.
If we're assuming
that u is expressed
as a function of the independent
variables x and y, then by du,
we mean delta u tan.
On the other hand,
if we inverted this,
du now-- in other words, what
do I mean by inverted this?
What I mean, first of
all, is if we assume now
that x and y are expressed in
terms of u and v-- for example,
suppose x is some function h of
u and v, what does du mean now?
Notice that now u
is playing the role
of an independent variable.
For the independent variable,
du just means delta u.
In other words, by way
of a very quick review,
notice that if we're viewing u
as being a dependent variable,
then du means delta u tan.
But if we're viewing u as
being an independent variable,
then du means delta u.
And consequently, the
results that we're using
hinge very strongly then--
in other words, the inversion
that we're using hinges very
strongly on the requirement.
In other words, the inversion
requires the validity
of interchanging delta u
and delta u tan, et cetera.
Now let me show you what
that means more explicitly.
Let's come back to something
that we were talking
about just a few moments ago.
From a completely
mechanical point of view,
given that u equals f of x,
y and v equals g of x, y,
we very mechanically
wrote down that du
was f sub x dx plus f sub y dy,
dv was g sub x dx plus g sub y
dy, and then we just
mechanically solved for dx
in terms of du and dv.
My claim is, is that if we
translate this thing, if we
translate this thing into the
language of delta u's, delta
x's, delta u tan's,
delta x tans, et cetera,
what we really said was what?
That delta u tan was the partial
of f with respect to x times
delta x, plus the partial of f
with respect to y times delta
y.
And delta v tan was the partial
of g with respect to x times
delta x, plus the partial of g
with respect to y times delta
y.
And then when we
eliminated delta y
by multiplying the
top equation by g sub
y and the bottom
equation by minus f sub y
and adding, what we found
was how to express delta x--
and catch this, this
is the key point--
what we did was we
expressed delta x
as a linear combination--
not of delta u and delta v,
but of delta u tan
and delta v tan.
You see, notice that the
result that we needed
to have to be able
to use differentials
was not this, but this.
See, we found this,
not delta x tan
equals g_y delta u minus f sub
y delta v over f sub x g sub y
minus f sub y g sub x.
To be able to say-- to invert
this required that this was
the expression that we
had, yet the expression
that we were really
evaluating was this one.
In fact, let me come
back for one moment,
and make sure that we see this.
You see, notice again
that the subtlety
of going from here to
here and inverting never
shows us that we've interchanged
the roles of u and v
from being the
dependent variables
to the independent variables.
So the reason that
there is so much
work done in advanced textbooks
under the heading of inverting
systems of equations
is to justify
that being able to switch
from delta x to delta x tan
or from delta u tan to delta
u as we see fit, whenever
it serves our purposes.
The validity of
being able to do that
hinges on this more
subtle type of proof,
that as far as I'm
concerned, goes
beyond the scope of our text,
other than for the fact that
in the learning exercises, I
will find excuses to bring up
all of the situations
that bring out
where the theory is important.
In other words, there
will not be proofs
of these more difficult things.
Not because the proofs
aren't important,
but from the point
of view of what
we're trying to
do in our course,
these proofs tend to obscure
the main stream of things.
So what I will do in the
learning exercises is bring up
places that will show you
why the theory is important,
at which point, I will emphasize
what the result of the theory
is without belaboring
and beleaguering you
with the proofs of these things.
At any rate, what
I'd like to do now,
next time, is to give
you an example where
all of the material, of the
blocks of material that we've
done now on partial derivatives,
are sort of pulled together
very nicely.
But at any rate, we'll talk
about that more next time.
And until next time, goodbye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.